It's okay girl, there is no reason to be nervous.
- Hi. - Hey. - Dr. Mike. - Oh, I know. I serve you coffee across the street... sometimes.
- I'm Tara. - Tara, right! Yeah, Tara who serves me coffee.
- That's me. - And I enjoy it every time. How are you? It's good to see you. - Me too.
- Wow, by the looks of this little lady she's been on the street a long time. - Don't I relate...
- To being on the street? -  It was a joke. I was just... - Oh you're not a...
- joking. - No, you're not prostitute.
Okay, so she still has her anterior fontanelle...
That's a soft spot, like babies have. Basically she has a little hole in her head.
- Oh poor thing. - No, no, but don't worry. Dr
Mike's got the cure. I'm gonna take her in the back for some x-rays on her noggin. You stay here.
Yeah, great
This is me and Brandi's spot ain't that right girl?
Wow so many kids out here. All my friends are having kids right now. My own family
asked me all the time with the hold of this. Yeah, what is the hold up? What's wrong with you?
What's wrong with me?
what's wrong with you
nothing
Nothing is wrong with me
seven cheating ex-boyfriends
Sorry
Thank you
But seriously what's wrong with you?
Already
Playing ball, you know how it is. So I think I'll give another try
It's hard to compete with the lady like Brandi
This is still just a dog day right? Yes still just a dog day
Folks we are certainly in the dog days of summer. It's gonna be
Keep the change. This is one dollar. Uh, here. You look beaut-
No offense but is your dog pregnant or just super fat?
I called you for pizza. Not opinions. This is why kids don't like old people.
He's lethargic
His appetite is down. Sam needs to get out there and meet some new dogs. That'll be $300
I found her yesterday. My little (?). It's so angry and happy at the same time.
Pregnancy has changed your sister. Move away from the door. She has a ridge of a chimp
You keep my dog alive until I get back from the hospital. My building has a strict no-dog policy. So i'll get a
How am I gonna get you up there?
Oh, come on in.
But it'd be possible to like volunteer, yes
Are you lost pumpkin? Can we keep her?
Joining us today is a former la Ramco
Doesn't know anything about hosting a morning news show.
The audience loves you two together.
Charlie every spot you've sniffed on this walk is the same.
Just pee ANYWHERE.
I wanna help you find your dog.
You should be my best friend. This dog has made us a family
Who's dog is that?
Almost don't recognize you without steam coming out to you
Our landlord just sold the building out from under us.
We got the new tricks charity events. Come on down
Dogs open their hearts to us to love and to be loved and I find that beautiful
Oh, that's just my equipment
Let them out. Whatever you think is happening is not
It's a dog.
Oh hi puppy